what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be doing a reaction video I'm going
to be reacting to the top 20 celebrities
who shut down sexist interview questions
it'll be interesting to see if I agree
if I also think that it is sexist but
before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it like the video that is the
most important metric that YouTube uses
to push you out in the algorithm so like
it takes a second come on help a girl
out okay so now we're gonna react
what are you looking for in a man now to
wear this cologne I'm not looking for a
man let's start there welcome to Ms Mojo
and today we're counting down our picks
for the top 20 celebs who shut down
sexist interview questions
if you do that to the guys
it's a thing that's just feel free to
embrace okay you know what's interesting
they only talk about sexism when it
comes to women when I see sexism for men
I would say more common in the media
um
like for example
the matter how many how many times has
that been said in a public platform I'm
sure I'm sure there are instances and
interviews that that has come up
and yeah it's all women oh we're so
oppressed okay I'll just I'm gonna try
to come in with an open mind I know I
know I know okay feminine slide mom I do
every single day if you could use makeup
or your phone one last time which one
would you pick
makeup or your phone is this what you
think girls have trouble choosing yeah
yeah absolutely for this list what are
you talking about yes
look at I'm not that big into makeup but
every day I walk down the street and I
see a [ __ ] that's got a cake on her
face
that's not it's not sexist men don't
wear makeup
and and your phone yeah like girls are
addicted to social media let's like
let's just stop capping
like criticizing part of our gender
doesn't make it sexist
we're looking at instances where stars
did not let sexist lines of questioning
fly which amazing responses
let us know in the comments all right
let's okay I thought we started okay
Megan 20. Megan Fox Megan's the real
deal this is this is actually a project
and a property that is very very close
to your heart uh give the audience that
little sense of why this one's so
important to you
um I mean I was a child of the 90s in
the 2014 film Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles Megan Fox played the iconic
character April O'Neil by taking on such
a well-known part she was inevitably
opening herself up to some level of
critique I didn't want her to have to be
rescued by her boyfriend or a guy like
that she only ever gets rescued by the
turtles and that was important to me
during this interview about the project
so let me get this straight
you don't think it's a little sexist to
say you'd rather be rescued by a turtle
than a man
uh maybe I'm tripping maybe maybe I'm
I'm tripping I'm sure I'm sorry I'm
tripping Fox was asked about whether now
was the time for more women to be taking
on leading roles in superhero films she
acknowledged that the question was inane
because how could anyone answer anything
but yes do you think that I would answer
no
no it is not realistic when you all have
Scarlett Johansson this five five girl
beating up dudes like I'm sorry if I'm
in trouble and someone sends a girl
that's smaller than me to help me
anyways okay I'll I'll listen I'll
listen I would answer anything but yes
to that question do you think I would be
like no it's not time for women to be in
movies
let's take it back 50 years this would
have been a good opportunity to ask some
more thoughtful questions that would
have garnered more nuanced and
compelling responses
number 19. Amy Schumer while promoting
her film train wreck Amy Schumer did an
interview where reporter Matt Tilley
asked her if Americans used the word
quote skanky when discussing her
character in the film do you have the
word skanky in America we do have that
word that word is an offensive one no
matter which side of the pond you hail
from and sure but
if the shoe fits if the shoe fit that's
not sex is
I'd call a dude a man [ __ ] I would call
the guy a man [ __ ] and just like I
would call girl hoe
or I don't really use the word skanky
that's more like a British you know term
but like yeah
I just feel like guys we are
grandmothers great grandmothers great
grandmothers may have faced real sexism
like they faced real sexism
not now you call a ho ho and Hell
Freezes Over okay whatever did not take
the line of questioning lying down I
better not come on that's the character
of the movie I'm not trying to offend
you whatever you're trying to do you are
that's a rude question she managed to
hurl insults at both his mother and wife
and made it clear that what he was
suggesting was inappropriate until we
get the car crash moment I mean that's
what we would love well then you're
gonna have to get it from your wife when
you go home let's luckily in the years
since uh okay if you've seen that movie
I've seen that movie and I it was a
decent movie like you know she's gonna
actress
sometimes in that movie I liked her and
there's a whole her whole character was
being a hoe that sleeps around and then
gets wiped up by like the nice guy it's
like why do you all sell these dreams to
women
oh usually anyways
promoting this film the entire media
industry has learned a lesson or two
about misogyny number 18 Charlize Theron
there's something feminist about this
film would you agree with that is a sort
of feminist film
um you know what I think is even more
powerful about it is that I think George
didn't have a feminist agenda up his
sleeve at the Cannes Film Festival
during a panel interview about Mad Max
Fury Road Charlize Theron was asked
where she Drew feelings of Rage from in
order to portray the character of
furiosa she had a snarky response at the
ready schooling the interviewer on the
fact that women experience strong
feelings of anger just like men do
you've got this this rage within you
where does it come from
a surprise women have that she's like
surprised we're crazy too we're CR
AP yeah look at it I think any dude
that's dated a crazy girl
you know we have right like let's start
I don't think that's sexist I just think
women in general don't express that
outwardly or men are more aggressive
outwardly
like how do I put it like
women are just seen as more like soft
and feminine and historically we have
been we're just a different breed of
women these days I don't know what to
tell you I'm not the only one
considering how much sexist dialogue was
already surrounding the expansion of the
Mad Max franchise we commend Theron for
staying as strong in real life as she
was in the movie George has this innate
understanding that women are just as
complex and interested interesting as
men and he was really interested in
discovering all of that number 17 Lake
Lively and I saw that this job isn't
just great because you get to borrow fun
clothes but it's great because
um because you get to stand for people
who need to be stood for while on the
red carpet for varieties power of women
New York luncheon where she was
promoting the child rescue Coalition
Blake Lively was asked a question that
had nothing to do with the cause she was
there to bring attention to an
interviewer from The Today shows online
Branch asked Lively what her quote power
outfit was and she snapped back about
how clothing should not be what they're
focusing on moment that we become more
aware
[Music]
whether the reporter would have asked a
man the same question and we've got to
assume they would not have I just I just
feel like we're
okay this this is what we're offended
about today someone asked you about your
dress I understand like it's it's a
an event for like a charity type thing
um but like a good cause I get that
but
I've been to events like okay probably
not that nice that's you know out of my
league but I've been to events like that
and
if someone asked me about my dress like
I wouldn't be tripping that's
I just feel like sometimes we we like
want to be victims like what what sexism
have you experienced in your life well
someone asked me about my dress once at
a event that I went to
huh huh I feel very grateful on the
other hand that we are all becoming so
much more conscious and we're becoming
so much more involved and we're becoming
active and I feel like there's an
Awakening that's happened number 16 Lady
Gaga also in your videos
has a strong sexual undertone how
important in your Artistry is this is
that it's a sexuality
it's as important to me as it is to you
isn't sex important to everyone all the
way back in 2009 when Lady Gaga wasn't
yet the mega star she is now she was
asked a question about whether she's
scared that the provocative nature of
her songs would overshadow her musical
Talent having sexual references can it
undermine the music because the sexual
references
um
a lot of people focused on that I'm not
scared are you scared no she responded
confidently that men who write songs
about sex are called Rock Stars while
she gets asked questions about whether
it will negatively affect her image but
when I do it my music and in my videos
because I'm a female because I make pop
music and you're judgmental and you say
that it is
distracting she ain't finished by yeah
because men and women are different
I mean if we're gonna go off a
technicality I guess maybe that one
qualifies
but not you know what not really no no
I'm I'm back up Becca if you're going to
be doing all this sexual stuff on camera
and it's a part of your shows you can't
be mad if someone asks you about it just
like if there was a magic mic Style Show
okay
few dudes doing like Magic Mike style so
it might be
like we're reaching like what I'm just
thinking we're talking to our grandmas
great grandmas from the 1920s and they
say what what sex does them have you
experienced and she said well
I was twerking on stage and someone
asked me about it
I think they might think we're soft I
don't know thing that she's just a rock
star and there's no way anyone could
deny that especially now after more than
a decade at the top of the music
industry I'm just a rock star number 15
Simone biles While most of the other
celebrities on our list are actors or
musicians this Olympic Athlete is also
not immune to receiving sexist questions
you let out this the signature Simone
smile after you did your trick which was
great but that was very authentic there
was an authenticity Simone biles
appeared on a season of Dancing With the
Stars and after one of her performances
host Tom Bergeron questioned why she
wasn't smiling when receiving
compliments about her performance I was
waiting for you to smile at some of the
compliments you didn't
come on Tom haven't we all learned by
now not to ask women to smile luckily
biles had oh wow oh no
oh I just we're looking to be if I swear
to God I just keep I keep thinking like
like lady from the 19 1900s saying like
what sexism do you experience and I said
well I was asked why I wasn't smiling
once like maybe you look sad I don't
know
I just I just feel like we're so quick
in this culture to be offended rather
than giving someone the benefit of the
doubt maybe she looked depressed
maybe like
I mean it's kind of awkward when
someone's saying great job and you're
like
and I I don't know a perfect response
ready saying that smiles don't win you
gold medals ain't that the truth the
last time I showed emotion it was at the
Olympics and I got a bronze instead of
gold number 14 Mark Ruffalo you know
sometimes exactly what I want to hear
isn't exactly what I want to hear
Scarlett Johansson is used to receiving
sexist questions while promoting Marvel
movies more on that later but in this
Cosmopolitan UK video the interviewer
decided to flip the script and let
Johansen take the serious questions
while Mark Ruffalo was offered the
queries typically asked to female stars
feel free to embrace your feminine side
Mark I do every single day and you put
the premiere tonight so Mark what are
you wearing on the red carpet this
evening
uh uh a suit he played up just how
ridiculous these standard questions are
when asked about his Red Carpet wardrobe
the most flattering poses for
photography and his diet and exercise
regimen so did you feel much pressure to
slim down and get in shape go on a diet
mark
not really I I uh ate a bunch of peanut
butter did some push-ups yeah I did some
push-ups I did my prison I have a prison
routine from here on out let's just ask
everyone the same questions no matter
their gender okay
number 13 Jennifer Aniston okay no
uterus no opinion it seems like there
have been Jennifer Aniston pregnancy
rumors on the cover of tabloids in line
at the grocery store for pretty much
decades now another wonderful photograph
which I've had to sort of live with for
the last God 10 15 years of picture of
me with a bump and a circle around my
stomach Aniston has understandably tired
of the persistent questions she receives
about her desire to be a mother and
explained in an interview with Allure
saying quote I don't like the pressure
that people put on me on women that you
failed yourself as a female because you
haven't procreated I don't think it's
fair okay it's not fair but that's
society I'm sorry it's just if you get
to a certain age as a woman and you
don't have kids people look at you kind
of funny and you can try to undo the
programming you can try to reprogram
people to think it's normal and think
it's not weird but throughout all of
human history women have reproduced the
majority of women have reproduced
the majority of men have not reproduced
throughout all of human history that's
why it's weird
anyways
um you're welcome to do what you want to
do but it's like you make your bed lie
in it you know that that happens and you
can't tell me Jennifer Aniston hasn't
had the chance to have children she's
stunning
went on to say that being maternal
doesn't simply need to be about having
biological children and that she is
mothering to her friends dogs and
Friends children yeah but
when you're 60 is that going to be
enough 70 when your looks good I mean
don't go me wrong her look she's kept up
her looks for a very long time but at
some point no one's lining up to date 70
year olds so what do you have then
myself with my amazing work my amazing
partner
my beautiful dogs and I tuned that noise
out you know I mean I think it's very
sweet that people uh
want
everything for me I'm so content and so
happy where I am number two you believe
that Taylor Swift
it's like you see the sad in her eyes
maybe she is what do I know what do I
know
we do oh no Taylor Swift is like like
I'm a t-swift fan I think she makes Bops
and I really liked the younger Taylor
Swift but you could see her over the
years getting like programmed by this
propaganda and the older she gets it's
like
the more the more victim she becomes
exist in this Society where women in
entertainment are discarded in an
elephant graveyard by the time they're
35. well be oh
I made Millions throughout my 20s
because I'm young beautiful and talented
and how I might make less money after 35
like
guys the world is what it is interviewed
by Germany's DPA Taylor Swift was asked
whether her 30th birthday would prompt
her to settle down with a man she
refused to answer saying quote I really
doubt men get asked the same question
when they turn 30. Swift seems like
something of a magnet for sexism and
while on the Grammys yeah because men
don't have a biological clock
okay carpet Nancy O'Dell of
Entertainment Tonight commented on
Taylor's physique saying she'd be quote
going home with lots of men to which
Taylor replied that she'd simply be
hanging out with her friends and going
home to her cats you're gonna walk home
with more than maybe just a trophy
tonight I think lots of men I'm not
going to walk home with any men tonight
I'm gonna I'm gonna go hang out with my
friends and then I go home to the cats
no men allowed men get me in trouble I
don't meow number 11. Rihanna during a
red carpet interview with the launch of
her Rogue man fragrance that's crazy all
these women benefit off of sexism like
they benefit off of Beauty in a way men
don't men have to be talented a lot of
these women wouldn't be where they are
if they weren't beautiful they weren't
stunning and they're okay with sexism or
an opportunity I don't even want to say
sexism but like opportunity
when it benefits them but the downside
that comes with it which is as you age
there's less
than they're mad it's like privilege is
invisible to those who have it and a lot
of women don't realize how privileged
they are and what position that they're
in especially like most of these women
are top 10 20 of beauty you know how
lucky you are to be born top 20 of
beauty 2014 Rihanna was asked by a
reporter what she's looking for in a man
to wear her new product the
multi-talented star took issue with the
very question itself responding
confidently that she's not looking for a
man period what are you looking for in a
man now to bring you ain't looking for a
man
but she you dated Chris Brown half your
20s Drake
and then now you're with that other
rapper but okay okay
I'm not looking for a man a start there
the question was freezed bizarrely
making it unclear whether the journalist
was asking Riri about her love life or
her business venture either way the
Starlet was having none of it when she
gave this sassy response because I feel
like I have so much more to do I feel
like
I mean icon that's such a big
title is such a big thing
um to say or to even be sad about myself
so
now the pressure's on I have to live up
to that number 10. Serena Williams do
you think you could ever beat a guy just
once
only guys sports are worth watching she
has the most number of singles doubles
and mixed doubles Grand Slam titles
among active players combined and was
ranked world number one eight times
between 2002 and 2017. Serena Williams
again so it's no exaggeration to call
Serena Williams skillful talented and
graceful when she's on the court but as
the only tennis player male or female to
win two of four grand slams seven times
each as well as the only one male or
female to earn 10 grand slams singles in
two different decades it's also clearly
no exaggeration to call her one of the
greatest athletes of all time period so
when a reporter asked her what it's like
to be quote one of the greatest female
athletes of all time she quickly and
admirably told the journalist what's
what I would really like to thank Sports
Illustrated for recognizing me not just
as sportswoman or Sports of the year but
just Sports person of the year number
nine
let her compete with the men then she
got beat by like the 250th dude
it just is what it look I'm a female
athlete okay I played volleyball I
played basketball I ran track in college
I I am an athlete and it's not fun I
don't enjoy that like a mid basketball
guy that played like two years in high
school could probably beat me even
though I played in college but it just
is what it is
like why are we trying to you know I'm
just gonna I'm gonna just play the video
I'm hearty you've done this before
many times when details about the Mad
Max reboot first came to light a lot of
conversation stemmed from the seemingly
female Centric take on a formerly Ultra
Macho franchise this naturally generated
a backlash online from people wanting to
boycott the film because of its alleged
feminist undertones I just wanted to ask
you as you were reading the script did
you ever think why are all these women
in here I thought this was supposed to
be a man's movie during a press
conference in Cannes that focused on
Fury Road the film's male lead Tom Hardy
was asked how he felt about all the
women in the movie his response was
simple but incredibly effective no
not for one minute number eight Kira
Knightley I think
that sometimes it is the people who no
one imagines anything of
who do the things that no one can
imagine after being honored with a
Hollywood film award for her portrayal
of Joan Clark in 2014's the imitation
game Keira Knightley was answering the
perfunctory backstage questions one
reporter asked a question that has been
posed to successful women for decades
how she manages to balance her career
and her personal life a question rarely
if ever asked if male actors or
politicians
okay
nightly was not gonna let it slide
though and followed up with a question
of her own oh boohoo
boohoo I got asked how I manage it all
stop it stop it
I'm just so tired of women playing the
victim to everything
oh boohoo I'm beautiful oh boohoo I I
I'm kidding I don't know what the hell
she will I don't understand movies like
I'm not a big movie person but like I'm
winning this award I'm doing good making
a ton of money
and now I'm gonna cry because someone
asked me how I balance my family
look at that's a valid question because
most women want to have families I don't
know if she's got one or what but it
must be hard to man it okay I'm just
gonna number seven Emma Stone I'm Emily
Jean Stone no Emma I love Emma Stone
don't
don't be talking about any woke [ __ ]
okay I'm just waiting Russell Garfield
and we are here at our Teen Vogue cover
shoot while the mid-2010 saw team Vogue
shifting towards more Cutting Edge
political coverage back in 2012 they
hadn't exactly hit their stride in terms
of their Progressive slant after
starring together in The Amazing
Spider-Man Emma Stone and Andrew
Garfield were interviewed for the
magazine Emma was asked about her hair
color at one point and in response began
to question why she frequently
experienced these sort of superficial
questions when Andrew interjected okay
I'll tell you why because Emma Stone is
one of the only celebrities that could
pull off every hair color
she's been blonde she's been red she's
been black hair brunette I have never
seen a girl that pulls off different
hair colors like Emma Stone
so you should take that as a compliment
because I don't think I could pull off
another hair color that well she said
quote you get asked interesting poignant
questions because you are a boy and shut
the whole thing down so because we
worked with uh I forget his name Andrew
Garfield or something right yeah
something like that yeah and how did
y'all get along did you get along okay
he's all right yeah it's fine yeah
number six Lauren Conrad make it you I
think that your home should reflect who
you are and your interests and you
should be surrounded by things that you
like and it should be very much your own
aesthetic Lauren Conrad managed to turn
a string of reality TV shows into a
full-fledged career as a lifestyle Guru
she's designed her own fashion line and
published a series of novels that's why
her response to a question posed on a
radio show was so delightfully perfect a
listener asked what her favorite
position was and after a moment of
contemplation she answered CEO favorite
position
CEO it even took the radio hosts a
minute to catch on to what she just said
CEO
number five I wouldn't I would say
that's inappropriate not sexist but yeah
Scarlett Johansson now were you able to
wear undergarments you're like the fifth
person that's ever no because what is
going on Ms Johansen is no stranger to
sexist interview questions and they came
in on a seemingly constant basis while
she did press for her role in The
Avengers movies for instance there was
this press conference in yeah I think
was sexist I think it was sexist to have
her do that role
because honestly like I swear to God I
swear to God if I am ever in trouble
okay this is this is controversial okay
so buckle up
if I'm ever getting robbed and they send
me a female police officer what is she
gonna do
what is she specially in the UK you guys
don't even have guns here
like in the U.S at least she's got a gun
you know that's better but like even so
if she's like a five five girl they
could just take it
um
I'm not even a big movie person I I
watched this movie but it was so long
ago but if I remember correctly
yeah no no no no no
but we'll see Robert Downey Jr was asked
about character development and Johansen
was asked about her Fitness regime
Auntie Scarlett to getting into the
shape of Black Widow did you have
anything special to do in terms of the
diet
um like you have to do eat some specific
food or that sort of thing instead of
responding she questioned why her
co-stars got the interesting questions
yeah
trying to beard Robert Downey Jr is a
better actor than you
half the reason you're here is because
you're hot but you're not complaining
about getting opportunity because you're
hot but then when someone comments on
you being hot boohoo cry me rough
while she was only asked about her
figure like how come you get like the
really interesting like existential
question and I get the like rabbit food
question similarly she seems to be asked
quite often about the undergarments she
wears under her Black Widow costume does
the Hulk have ripped up CGI tighty
whities under his ripped up CGI pants we
may never know is it inappropriate to
ask somebody what kind of Underpants
they wear I didn't ask you what kind you
just asked me if I was wearing any
number four Rowan Blanchard
I've been waiting for a day like this to
come the girl meets Worldstar had the
perfect response when a red carpet
reporter once asked her if she had any
dieting tips for other teenage girls
Blanchard who was only 13 at the time
told Elle that she questioned whether
they'd ever ask about dieting tips for
teenage boys I kind of feel strongly
about everything especially anything
that relates to girlhood and being a
girl she went on to assert that she does
not diet I mean they might ask that if
the dude's Jack
and that if she has one food related tip
for fans it's that quote if you don't
order fries you'll probably be mad
poignant and true our image has always
been kind of painted by men or four men
so why is she this young spewing this
nonsense she's supposed to be a kid when
you see it she's not supposed to hate
men at freaking 13 years old take a
selfie in public and she's literally in
control of how she wants to look and how
she wants to be portrayed there's such
power in that number three there's power
in taking a selfie oh my God
pathway after having a much reported
upon wardrobe malfunction at the
premiere of her 2012 film Les Miserables
Anne Hathaway sat down with the Today
Show's Matt Lauer he jumped right into
things by asking her what was the lesson
learned I was very sad that we live in
an age when someone takes a picture of
another person in a vulnerable moment
and rather than delete it and do the
decent thing sells it rather than
allowing herself to be blamed she turned
his question around and put the blame
squarely on the photographer and the
population who will pay for such an
image and I'm sorry that we live in a
culture that commodifies sexuality of
unwilling participants which brings us
back to Les Mis because that's what my
character is she is someone who is
forced to sell sex to benefit her child
because she has nothing and there's no
social safety net stop it stop it
there are single fathers out there and
they have to get a job you are not
forced to be a hooker oh my
stop it
you're good
look I understand there's hard times I
understand there's people that have been
in situations where they have to make
decisions that I will never have to make
but nobody forced you to be a hooker no
no one forced you'd be hooker
anyways and I yeah so um unfortunately
this wasn't the only time Hathaway was
faced with sexist questions while doing
press for the Dark Knight Rises Anne
Hathaway was asked about her feline
Fitness routine what is the feline
Fitness regime
um a lot it's it's it's all the boring
stuff that no one ever wants to do it's
just watch what you eat and get yourself
to the gym after trying to deflect the
line of questioning away from our
Catwoman costume and her body she
finally had enough of his persistence
and she turned the question right back
on him any particular workout I'm trying
to lose weight well what's what's the
deal man you look great no no no no
seriously that we have to talk about
this what what do you want are you
trying to fit into a cat suit number two
Ariana Grande the side to side singer
was not going to take any gendered
questions when she was participating in
a radio interview in the mid-2010s the
hosts of the show who all happen to be
male asked her if she had to give up one
thing her cell phone or her makeup which
it would be if you could use makeup or
your phone one last time which one would
you pick
your makeup or your phone is this what
you think girls have trouble choosing
yeah yeah absolutely
spawned right away by letting them know
she thought the question was a sexist
one ladies
boys as the interview went on however
they continued to put an emphasis on
things that girls do and she eventually
had to lay down the bruh I mean
guys some stereotypes exist for a reason
I'm a girl I'm addicted to my phone half
the [ __ ] I know are addicted to their
phones can we just stop playing
can we stop playing blessing blessing
he's camera shy he's not gonna be on
camera
your girl always on her phone
wait it just is what it is yeah there's
a lot of dudes that are addicted to
video games
you know you know someone a dude that's
addicted to video games
yeah yeah does that make me sexist
no no so why do these like why
she's offended over that it's true um
a lot for them boys you need a little
brushing up on equality over here come
on before we continue be sure to
subscribe to our Channel and ring the
bell to get notified about our latest
videos you have the option to be
notified for occasional videos or all of
them if you're on your phone make sure
you go into your settings and switch on
notifications
number one Helen Mirren do you think I
mean you are in quotes a serious actress
um
today feminism is no longer a dirty word
and many stars proudly claim it in 1975
however speaking up about issues of
sexism was much more difficult and not
always as well received I do find in
fact that this what could be best
described as your equipment in fact
hinders you perhaps in that Pursuit I'd
like you to explain what you mean by
Michael Helen Mirren appeared on Michael
Parkinson's iconic Chat Show early in
her career and found herself cornered
into an uncomfortable conversation
serious actress because serious
actresses can't have big bosoms is that
what you mean well I think that they
might sort of detract from a performance
if you know what I mean parking seemed
to focus on her body rather than her
abilities
okay stop it
oh you if you you will go somewhere
where you won't
your looks be the focus go be an
engineer
go lay bricks
why why do women that you go put
yourself on a screen where they're
looking for beautiful women and then
complain that people notice that you're
beautiful go lay bricks
oh
yes and while the clip is uncomfortable
to watch seeing mirin own him is totally
worth it what a crummy performance if
people are obsessed with the size of
your [ __ ] or anything else I would hope
that uh
the performance and the play and the
living relationship
between all the people on the stage and
all the people in the audience overcome
such
nasty it didn't because that's still the
quest nutty asked